Tengo mayor confianza.
(Risas)
Tengo la confianza de que les daré
la charla más vomitiva de todas, tan vomitiva que
querrán levantarse de sus asientos e irse.
Estoy a punto de mostrarles cosas
que sus ojos no podrán creer,
todo en nombre de la ciencia.
Para empezar, para quienes no saben a qué me dedico,
y si tuvieran que resumirlo en pocas palabras,
dirían que soy un cantante de beatbox.
(Hace beatbox) Por ejemplo...
les muestro:
(Hace beatbox)
(Cambios rítmicos)
(Tararea una tonada)
(Aplausos)(Vítores)
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Y ser un artista del beatbox,
significa que profesionalmente
dependo al cien por ciento...
(Hace beatbox) de la flexibilidad de la voz humana no filtrada.
Y durante años, a mis colegas y a mí nos han preguntado cosas como:
"¡Ay, por Dios! Eso es alucinante.
¿Cómo te enteraste que podías hacerlo?"
Después de practicar muchísimas horas...
(Risas)
"¿Y de qué trabajas realmente?"
"Beatbox de tiempo completo, Su Señoría".
Pero la verdadera pregunta que me hacen con frecuencia
y que es un poco más complicada de responder
es "¿Cómo lo haces?"
"¿Cómo haces esos sonidos?"
Es decir, sé que la memoria muscular determina dónde pongo los labios
para así...
(Hace beatbox)
pero no tengo la más mínima idea sobre toda la mecánica interna.
Ya saben, todas esas partes pegajosas y cosas colgantes
y cómo se relacionan para que...
(Risas)
de tal manera me permita...
(Hace beatbox)
Para decirlo con una metáfora:
sé conducir,
pero no sé qué hay debajo de la cubierta del auto.
Así que me propuse averiguarlo
e invitar a un público cautivo de 5000 personas,
unas cuantas cámaras invasivas,
a todos los que están mirando esto en línea y su historial
a un lugar recóndito al que ni mis conocidos más íntimos han ido:
mi garganta.
Y para ayudarme a hacer eso
quisiera presentar a un invitado especial
de Queensland Voice Center.
Un hombre que ha estado en mi boca demasiadas veces para admitirlo,
una celebridad de la laringe,
al otorrino y cirujano de la laringe,
¡Mathew Broadhurst!
(Aplausos)(Vítores)
MB: Gracias, Tom, muchas gracias.
Y muy buenas noches a todos.
Es un placer estar aquí en el escenario TEDx esta noche.
(Risas)
Uff.
TT: No se está calentando las manos.
Esto no se pone tan íntimo.
MB: Hace un tiempo nos propusimos ir a las profundidades del mundo de...
y de la garganta de...
este extraordinario cantante de beatbox
para comprender cómo puede ser humanamente posible toda esa variedad de sonidos.
Y descubrimos
-- estas cosas se meten en la boca --
y descubrimos algo absolutamente asombroso.
Aún con dos años de prácticas quirúrgicas en la laringe
en la Escuela de Medicina de Harvard
con el mundialmente famoso profesor Steven Zeitels,
jamás hemos visto algo tan extraordinario ni fascinante como esto,
y eso es lo que vamos a mostrarles esta noche
(Risas)
Con aviso previo para aquellos que sean un poco delicados
los siguientes diez minutos serán cada vez más explícitos
y nauseabundos,
así que allá vamos allá...
TT: Pueden usar la bolsa.
(Risas)
MB: Entonces, cuando hacemos un sonido,
usamos las cuerdas vocales para tomar aire de los pulmones
y la convertimos en una columna de aire que vibra en la garganta.
Si imaginan que esto es una trompeta
aquí tenemos la boquilla -- o sea, las cuerdas vocales --
y el cuerno sería la garganta.
Si sacáramos la cabeza,
sacáramos un poco del cuello,
y dejáramos únicamente el torso con solo las cuerdas vocales vibrando
emitiría un sonido así.
(Sonidos flatulentos)
TT: (Tono agudo)
MB: Sería complicado comunicarse, pero tenemos una garganta.
Tenemos todos los tejidos suaves
que es lo que nos da toda la variedad increíble de sonidos
que escucharemos esta noche.
Ahora, esto es un laringoscopio rígido.
TT: Hmm, sugestivo.
(Risas)
MB: Lo sé.
Con 10 mm de diámetro
nos muestra una imagen de la laringe con la mejor calidad posible.
Lo conectamos con un estroboscopio
y con un micrófono que actúa de disparador.
El micrófono captará las frecuencias
y eso nos permitirá mostrarles cómo funciona todo esto.
¿Podemos apagar las luces?
TT: (Tono grave)
MB: Prende la luz aquí.
TT: (Tonos agudos y graves)
MB: La frecuencia de sonidos está pareja con la del estroboscopio.
Es la luz que están viendo en la taza.
TT: (Tono grave)
MB: Y está más o menos a unos 80 Hertz.
Entonces, ahora podemos sacar eso
y desfasar el estroboscopio y el sonido.
Esto nos permite captar la actividad de los tejidos que vibran en tiempo real.
Cuando aplicamos lo mismo a la laringe,
aparece este movimiento lento y fluido de la vibración de las cuerdas vocales.
Así que esto es lo que vamos a empezar a hacer.
¿Estás listo?
TT: Sipi.
(Risas)
MB: Aquí vamos.
Vamos a echarle un vistazo a la caja de voz.
(Risas)
No es fácil no sentir nauseas por esto.
Di í.
TT: (Cantando) Í...
MB: Al fondo pueden ver las cuerdas vocales,
esas miniestructuras de cuerda,
(Risas)
Y ahora miren la piel sobre el cuello
y verán qué tan potente es la luz que lo traspasa.
Listo, ¿podrían volver a encender las luces?
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Muy bien, vuelve a decir í con calma.
TT: (Cantando) Í.
(Risas)
(La audiencia se asombra)
MB: Esas son las cuerdas vocales vibrando
a unos 120 Hertz.
Eso quiere decir que chocaron unas 120 veces por segundo
para hacer ese sonido.
También podemos ver que son completa y perfectamente normales.
Por lo que pese a todos esos años con el beatbox,
en el modo en el que lo hace Tom,
no provocaron daño alguno a su garganta.
Es realmente impresionante.
Lo hiciste bien.
Muy bien.
TT: (Tono agudo)
Es pan comido.
MB: Ahora miren cómo las cuerdas vocales van de sonido agudo a grave.
Verán abrirse y alargarse para luego cerrarse y tensarse.
Ahora di Í.
TT: (De tono agudo a grave) Í.
MB: Muy bien.
MB: Y van a ver que su rango de voz es tan amplio
mucho más amplio que el del cualquier artista que haya analizado
que la máquina realmente no puede captar los tonos más agudos.
TT: (Tono agudo)
MB: Sabemos que el registro de silbido está entre unos 2092 Hertz.
Significa que las cuerdas vocales
se están golpeando más de 2000 veces por segundo
solo para emitir ese sonido.
Es verdaderamente asombroso.
Si se ponen a pensar, solo tienen 15 mm de largo.
Eso es apenas el ancho de un pulgar.
Es increí...
(Risas)
Es impresionante que este órgano pueda hacer esto.
Y ahora vamos a cambiar por el laringoscopio flexible.
Esto va a ser un poco más explícito.
TT: Lo compró en la SEXPO.
(Risas)
MB: Eso no estaba en el guion.
(Aplausos)
TT: Usado.
(Risas)
MB: Ahora, hemos tenido que coordinarlo perfectamente
debido al empleo de la anestesia local.
Se debe adormecer la nariz y meter la cámara adentro.
No ayuda a la hora de producir un montón de sonidos
pero nos dará una vista genial de lo qué pasa ahí adentro.
Así que contengan sus estómagos y veamos qué podemos hacer.
(La audiencia se asombra)
Vamos a la parte posterior de la nariz.
Ahí pueden ver el paladar blando.
Mucho de los sonidos que emitimos día a día,
hasta los más simples.
son increíblemente complejos.
Por ejemplo, el sonido "kh".
Es el paladar blando que choca contra la parte posterior de la nariz.
Si lo dicen fuertemente cinco veces
y sienten cómo el paladar blando chasquea atrás de la garganta.
Kh, kh, kh, kh, kh, kh.
Muy bien, cuando Tom lo hace se ve así
TT: Kh, kh, kh, kh.
Una cacofonía de cucaburras y cacatúas cacareando en Kakadu
causado por consumir la ketamina.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
MB: Muy bien, por supuesto,
en el mundo del beatbox, pueden usar eso para diversos efectos.
Te ayudo.
TT: No pasa nada, somos profesionales.
(Risas)
(Hace beatbox)
MB: Muy bien.
(Aplausos)(Vítores)
Ahora, vamos a deslizarnos un poco más al fondo.
Si pudieran apagar las luces
y fijarse si pueden ver la luz en algún rincón de la boca.
Podrán ver exactamente dónde está la cámara.
(Risas)
TT: (Cantando)
¡Sorpresa!
(Risas)
MB: Muy bien.
(La audiencia se asombra)
Lo que pueden ver ahí, es la base de la lengua.
Los muros laterales en la pantalla
son la faringe.
Y las paredes musculares,
con las cubiertas profundas y oscuras son la laringe.
TT: ¿No deberíamos prender las luces de vuelta?
No es mala la idea.
Que así esto se está volviendo asqueroso.
MB: Prendan las luces, gracias.
Muy bien.
Ahora, durante mi vida he examinado más de 15 000 laringes y gargantas
puedo asegurarles que la de Tom es tan anatómicamente normal
como la de cualquier otro.
Es solo que usa todos los músculos y tejidos suaves en una forma única
que le permite hacer todos los sonidos espectaculares que van a oír.
Ahora vamos a examinar algunos de esos sonidos para Uds.
TT: Está realmente ahí adentro. Sin dudas.
(Risas)
OK.
(Sonidos agudos)
(Ululato)
MB: Ahora está cambiando la forma
y la longitud de la columna de aire
mediante contracciones rítmicas de todos los músculos
para generar todos esos sonidos que están escuchando.
(Hace beatbox)
(Risas)
(Tono grave)
MB: Y ahora hay movimientos rítmicos de los...
esos de ahí son los cartílagos aritenoides
moviéndose de adelante para atrás creando ese sonido.
TT: (Tono grave)
MB: Nos gusta llamarlo el "bajo esfinteriano"
(Risas)
Y lo que pueden ver es que al colapsar todos los tejidos...
permite una nota de bajo distinta y realmente profunda.
Muy bien, ahora con el efecto de la anestesia local
y con una manguera negra en la nariz,
vamos a dejar que nos muestre su repertorio
y ver cómo actúa todo.
Y lo moveremos...
con cuidado.
TT: ¿Podrías subirlo un pelín más arriba?
(Risas)
TT: (Hace beatbox)
Tal vez un poquito más...
(Risas)
Bueno, creo que ya estamos.
(Hace beatbox) A todos los que vinieron a calar hondo
tan hondo como el abismo...
miren esto.
(Hace beatbox)
(Vítores)
(Aplausos)
(Hace beatbox)
Empezamos con los fundamentos y construimos de la nada.
(Sonido de disco interrumpido)
Sí, así.
(Hace beatbox)
(Sonidos de trompeta)
(Aplausos)(Vítores)
(Silbidos)
TT: Muchísimas gracias.